hi everyone it's Jerry I have a game to
share with you from
1958 on the white end miracle babatov
and he's playing against Mikhail tall
there is one main takeaway for me from
this one that comes out of the middle
game of this king's Indian defense
variation
okay it's on this move six where tall
puts pressure on the weakest Square in
Weiss Camp D4 as a whole
additional defense of that
Knight D7 Queen D2 Pop Quiz how would
you react as black here feel free to
pause the video
okay here we go best move is the move
played in the game A6
now I want to draw attention to this
moment in the game because I think many
players would go astray
and by a stray I mean release the
tension in this case
why would you maybe want to do this well
the queen Knight has a couple new
squares
at the same time note how you would be
helping the king Knight this is a
perfect square perfect Outpost
also the bishop now has finally legal
moves probably to E2 in White's moment
away moments away from completing
development castling
on the king side same side's castle
position
it is best to maintain the tension
note one of the deficiencies with the
zamish variation is that the king side
minor pieces are stepping on one
another's toes
for as long as you maintain the tension
as black you are in a way keeping a
question mark over the head of the king
Knight
it's asking itself do I go to G3 do I go
to C1
note if you're going to F4 that would be
losing as well
because now you could take on D4
and follow up with the fork
my point here is that if you're giving
this Knight the D4 Square this post is
far preferable
to G3 or C1 if you really do want to
release the tension on D4 it's best to
consider it more closely only after this
Knight has already moved from E2
I didn't point this out yet A6 is not
just some waiting move
it is Paving the way for Benco Gambit
style play B5 is right around the corner
pitching upon in many lines is a way to
play this
you do get the open lines on the queen
side
play follows with Queen side castles a
case of opposite sides castles and this
game is present
if
well first of all this is not most
common nowadays
Rook to D1 is more common with an eye on
the same size Castle's position
now a way that the structure could
change at this point after A6
is with D5 I want to give you a feel for
how you could position your pieces and I
want to show you this B5 move in action
give you an idea of how you can be
following up
you can start with Knight to E5
something has to be done about C4
let's say the Knight moves to allow this
defense you could already play B5
and after it takes it's already Gambit
play don't take straight away
the bishop would be able to recapture in
one move and develop
best to bring this Knight into the mix
with an eye on C4
as well as
an F5 break
black already has the king tucked away
there's still a couple Tempe needed by
white to have the king tucked away
in general as black therefore we should
be welcome to creating Pawn tension
everywhere and soon both sides of the
board are going to be lit up a lot of
open lines right around the corner here
it's a way to go just wanted to give you
a feel a few moves down the road in the
event of D5
in this game opposite sides castles
position followed up with Queen A5 King
B1 very standard
to watch over A2 as well as
set up another
common move that you would also see
against the
Sicilian Dragon that's sort of a that's
what we kind of have by transposition
a sicilian Dragon here
B5 on board
and now Knight to D5 so
this right here is the middle game
takeaway for me from this game
how to react to White's last move I
should point out
that this move is considered best I'm
not going to share any lines if you want
to experiment on your own feel free to
do that
move playing in the game is a move I
think you could see plenty of players go
with
What's Happening Here Queen is hit Pawn
is hit how do you deal with that
what do you think Tal's move is in this
position feel free to pause the video
okay here we go move played in the game
is
Knight takes night
tall rarely does he have a a retreat in
him
he's giving up the queen
for two minor pieces
one of the points with King to B1
I should note is that
when you play Knight D5 now if you take
Queen takes Queen it is not with check
so
in this position Queen takes Queen would
be a losing move for black because white
could go with the in-betweener Knight
takes Pawn check and only then scoop up
the queen this is a decisive Advantage
for white
okay well there is no Queen takes Queen
here it's Knight takes Knight Queen
takes Queen this is a sound sacrifice
black is for Choice here
also after Knight takes Bishop that
wasn't just any Bishop that was won that
was maybe the four point Bishop that was
the better Bishop the one that ties in
better with the
Central structure which is primarily on
light
okay the smoke has not yet cleared this
night
hitting the rook and C4
Knight takes C4
and this Knight is just too good
on this post it's much more valuable
it's not your ordinary three-point night
so it is worth about a rook maybe four
and a half points so
it's knocked out straight away
if you're trying to work around it
um I don't know Queen to E1 now you have
to deal with this past Pawn this Knight
is still alive and maybe reinforced
one way or the other
okay Rook takes Knight follows
Pawn takes and Knight to C1 so the
imbalance here we have
an unopposed dark Square Bishop
and a rook versus a queen basically
and since its opposite sides castles
there's no fear
um there's a lot of fear for the white
king but not the black king this guy
here is way too good a Defender
for white to even uh think of starting
up some attack it's just not happening
so this is very very one-sided type
position in going for this sequence
going for this imbalance
considered best is Knight to F4 instead
of this Knight C3 move but it's a very
very difficult
task ahead for team white no matter how
you look at it
it's just a very important ID to be
familiar with giving up the queen for
the two minor pieces
let's see how
all the black pieces soon swarm the
white king
Rook B8
Bishop C4 Knight B6
and then Bishop D2 these last two moves
are interchangeable
and what are we doing about the pressure
on B4 it's just way way too much this
last move throws the game away it's
completely lost from this point on
considered the best attempt for white
is to bring this Knight back to E2
to try and stop the bishop and Rook from
observing B2 directly
planting the Knight on C3 in other words
okay that's not played instead Queen D2
Bishop gets out of the way which allows
this guy to advance
Knight E2 now but by this point it's too
late
C4 hits Bishop is kicked from defending
C4
C3 hits not only hitting the queen but
this Knight
eyeing up the C4 Square
so
no good solution here for white
what is tried is Queen D3
if you're taking this that's going to
hurt B2 is collapsing and so is White's
game
so Queen keeps the Knight out of that
monster Square
now there's a past Pawn
what's tried here is Knight D4
cuts out the Bishop from seeing a couple
squares C3 B2 but
here come the other pieces Bishop
watches over the Knight moves
C6 primarily and the final piece is
ready to enter the attack
Rook D1
Rook F to C8 and Bishop to B3
from here Knight A4 how do we get to
that C3 Square
well I'm sorry should you allow the
Knight to get to C3 no that's going to
be absolutely devastating so
the Knight is knocked out there aren't
any tries I I tested out this position
right here I was like could white
actually get a little crazy and take
this Pawn allow a discovery that is just
not going to end well
so in this position it was Rook to D1 if
white is trying to knock out the pawn
here are a few ways white could get hurt
Knight A4 is double check
if you go to the corner there's Rook B4
taking advantage of the pined Knight
King A3 there's Knight B2
hitting the queen
once more with an i in the C4 Square
that's not going to end well
if you go here you drop the Knight
if you go here
that's not only me but
a pretty Fork to end as well got that
square covered
anything more Queen there you're just
asking for this one Knight C4 around the
corner one final variation is this one
here
King C1 don't forget
this guy could go to this diagonal as
well
which paves the way for another Fork
what a guy that night always Landing a
fork
however you slice it okay
from here it is Rook to D1 that bond is
definitely poison
Rook fc8 Bishop B3 Knight A4 Knight has
to go cannot allow it to get there if
you try to defend with Knight E2 in
comes Bishop B5 knock out the Knight hop
into C3 no saves here
for white
so game finishes up like this bishop A4
Rook is hit
if you go here you're getting mated
if you go here we can knock out the
Knight
and then made on C2
okay Knight B3 in the game
as soon as the Knight is out of The
Bishop's way
we have that intersection Square
hops right to it
Queen takes a bishop takes Knight
they are stacked on the C file
nothing
to do about Rook C1
certainly can't take the pawn here
we'd have discover check and the queen
would be
falling next so what is played is Queen
A3
Rook C1
Rook takes
Rook takes and white resigns its
Checkmate next move in
three ways
the king went here
well that's the only move after King
there we have mate like this
like this or
if the game actually did play out to me
I think tall would go with
that one for me
a rare under promotion to a bishop for
me is what we could have had if it went
straight to mate in this game but he
resigned instead of playing King to A2
interesting game this one here again the
main takeaway was the two minor pieces
for the queen imbalance
it's perfectly sound black is certainly
for choice in that imbalanced
uh possession in that imbalanced middle
game slash end game so let's have a look
at the tail the tape with this one
you can see that it is clean right here
after B5 it doesn't like the idea to
jump in there with Knight to D5
is considering D takes
D takes C instead but after hopping in
it does in fact like the idea to take on
D5 give up the queen
and yeah I get the two minor pieces
Knight takes Bishop
on E3 next
and that's a very big Bishop that dark
Square Bishop
in the end we have
a handful inaccuracies mistakes blenders
there this is really the main one
that first inaccuracy
Knight D5 not the way to go and it was
downhill from there
88 inaccuracy
uh 88 accuracy I should say for white
and Tall playing at 95 accuracy
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video and in the
comments section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
foreign